either your val your gal or your pal i
think that's pretty much it i like that
lots of ways to celebrate for sure well
i just make sure it's something cool
this year because we've got a almost a
heat wave coming definitely for the
southwest for us it's gonna feel very
spring-like this week nice clear skies
for our tuesday morning temperatures
have been in the 40s generally around
town but a couple of spots have dropped
to the 30s this morning seven hills
nellis red rocks in the mid 30s not too
much in the way of wind kyle canyon is
in the mid 30s i don't want to bring it
down when we've got such a beautiful
forecast but we are desperately in need
of rain across the west because we
finished off 2021 so nice with lots of
snowpack in the inner mountain west and
all the mountain ranges and good
rainfall but now for the new year we
have been so dry we need storms in the
west they've all been back east and
we've got extreme to excessive droughts
drought conditions in parts of central
nevada with severe drought status over
southern nevada so we sure need some
rain we're not getting it today and it's
not in the eight day forecast 72 degrees
we were 65 yesterday we're going up to
72 today more than 10 degrees above the
normal average high of 61. we'll be a
lot closer to records this week than we
will the average high sunrise 6 35 and
sunset at 5 15 gives us a little bit
more daylight to enjoy these beautiful
temperatures but the high pressure will
be very intense and as it strengthens
it's going to drive temperatures way
above normal in southern california they
have heat watches
already issued for wednesday through
friday evening for a large area of
southern california where they're
looking for mid to upper 80s to near 90
degrees
for the latter half of the week and
these 80s will hold on through the
weekend even for kickoff of super bowl
sunday where they're looking for maybe
the warmest kickoff temperature ever for
a super bowl oh my goodness that's crazy
72 degrees for us again today we'll keep
it in the low 70s for a couple more days
slide into some very warm mid 70s on
friday and then we'll look for those
mornings of course to be much milder too
in those upper 40s to low 50s the trend
lasts all the way through valentine's
day and then a cooler system does arrive
across the southwest and it will cool us
all down we'll get back to some mid 60s
by tuesday